this talk to us about this article you
did also on the neighboring state not
too far from Russia Bosnia the former
Yugoslavia and it's interesting I mean
you know more and more people come from
if my work you know more and more people
reach out to me and asked me to cover
the issues which share the concern about
I would say you know the taught my head
in the last six to twelve months I've
had you know many dozen or maybe a color
dozen people from you know Bosnian
Muslims reach out to me to buy a Twitter
or our email I've seen you to comment on
the situation there and so I said last
week I was really doing a deep dive into
the current situation I mean I mean it's
not a stretch to say that we you know
we're on the eve of the vote or another
Bosnian Muslim genocide now the risk of
sounding that mean it might sound like a
totally to some but again the Russia is
using the same paramilitary group to use
the new Ukraine the no no wolves barking
in there the Soviet republic would be in
bosnia-herzegovina if you look at the
leaders and a leader of that entity that
Bosnian herpetic NDMC they're openly
talking about separating and created
their own Serbian state or joining
Serbia itself you see a lot of empty
Muslim Islamophobia rhetoric which comes
along with that and Russia is their
sowing discord and not only some discord
but also army pellets of a paramilitary
groups and also arming that Soviet
entity will be in bosnia-herzegovina so
it's very frightening Bosnian Muslims
who live in the Bosnian Muslim in place
within the state yeah you know in
Christian world and a fearful that you
know the darkest days of their history
will you know be revisited upon them so
do you feel now is the evidence showing
is it that the Dayton Peace Agreement is
is something that could potentially just
fold
yeah absolutely I mean you know you've
got you know hyper the nationalists
ultra nationalist sentiment sweeping all
across Europe and so you know you know
Republican scare has been no you no
stranger to that either so when you have
hyper nationalistic sentiment where you
have a will for people to separate and
sort of totally create their own states
you know at the expense of a another
minority or a neighboring state and you
know dangerous things usually follow so
you know the situation there is
increasingly concerning do you know of
any other country that has in its
country usually you have a prime
minister you have a president one person
that's in charge but people don't know
it's kind of unique to Bosnia you have
three presidents running one country how
does that work yeah it's one nation
state governed by free basically
protectorates within no sex or free you
know and it is you go to pro identity
but a Bosnian Muslim entity and also the
assuming in cities so you know those you
know the people within each of those
states vote for their own particular
leader but at the end of the day you
really only have one state now that's
fine and finally Danny and it's kind of
worked for the last you know what 2025
years to a point but the problem is now
with the Saudi engineer obscure being on
the border of Serbia it's you know
severe has made no secret of the fact
that they would like to claim that
territories their own and also you know
and that's why they're whipping up you
know separatists sentiment within that
is this really possible see Jake because
so much money has been invested you have
the economy start I mean things are
starting to pick up you would think
people who visited from who know the
situation from the past if they go there
it seems like everything has been
rebuilt the things are functioning is
this really something that's that's
possible to happen again yeah I mean you
know unfortunately you know despite
times you cannot prevent you know
political entrepreneurs who use separate
an ultra nationalist rhetoric rhetoric
that demonizes a minority or a certain
ethnic group you know for the purpose of
mobilizing and seizing political power
and so you know in that Republic you do
have that sentiment going and paper wall
you know and also states acting away
which is not in their their best
interests you know for the short-term
political gain ever the cost of you know
the well-being or the site going forward
is this something that the US would have
any control over or would allow because
the US was there as the peace keeping
force would they allow something like
this to happen well you know it took a
long time before Clinton you know Anna
Devane there
in fact European leaders turned their
back on the genocide which was taking
place because you know let's be honest
even Muslim lives don't matter you know
in the corridors of European power so
you know they allowed the slaughter to
take place you know there was a long
period of political inaction
Clinton's hand was forced eventually and
he eventually intervened but you know I
we now you know Donald Trump is not Bill
Clinton um and we know how Donald Trump
feels about Muslims in the Muslim world
he's completely different if not hostile
to that now you know you know what
people said you know came to power and I
suppose a non-interventionist promise
you know and he's he political bachelor
doesn't want you to engage in foreign
military actions I just wanted to these
heavy metals reaction across the wall
right now but yeah to be honest I can't
predict I'll trunk would react you know
if I said wow this is uh this is really
uh sad to hear that after all this time
that something like this can erupt again
and one last question one last question
on this topic for the people that don't
know is it true that this was the
greatest genocide that happened after
World War Two in BA
the server needs a genocide stands is
one of the worst episodes of ethnic
cleansing in Europe after the Second
World War
over 28,000 unarmed Bosnian Muslim men
and boys were massacred by the Bosnian
Serb military forces while thousands of
women were raped by the end of the war
over 64,000 Bosnian Muslims were killed
half of them civilians around 50,000
women and girls were raped thousands
were forced to leave their homes the
majority of whom never returned against
Muslims their yeah European Holocaust Oh
your second Holocaust in the 20th
century you know you know only you know
40 50 years after the Second World War
so yeah it's you know those those ill
feelings that they're communal and
sectarian ill feeling remains in each
states but also it's been you know
fueled by the international sentiments
or about the region one more one more
I'm sorry because you mentioned
Holocaust and that's something obviously
you know this sad tragic event that
happened and it's talked about so much
in the essence that it doesn't repeat
again why don't you hear much about the
Bosnian the Muslim Baz in a holocaust
that happened against Muslims so it
doesn't repeat again yeah the world I
mean what is one of the community done
to to stop Mimas campaign of ethnic
cleansing against you know 1.2 million
Rohingya Muslims it's nothing what is
the international community doing
against China's efforts with nickey
planes up to the 12 million Wigan
Muslims at the moment nothing I mean not
only is the world you know an eager
Rwanda genocide which certainly didn't
have Muslims involved but if you look at
the track record of the international
community stepping in to halt genocide
where the majority of the population is
Muslim it has become we can also look at
Syria what does the international
community to hold you know Assad is
killing of displacing about warming
mostly Sunni Muslims in Syria